[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle isabelle
duquesne et je suis consultante en
responsabilité sociétale rs je vais vous
parler du rôle de la paix dans mon
travail il y une quinzaine d'années dans
une université de tokyo
je discutais avec un collègue sur les
courts en pacifiste depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale nous remarquions
que à l'ouest comme à l'est une
politique de réarmement reprenait mais
pourquoi je demandais le mur de berlin
vient de tomber
qu'est ce qui nous incite à reprendre ce
chemin mon ami japonais rétorqua aisée
belles pièces boring one is born
la pêche c'est l'ennui oui c'est vrai
quand il y à la paix il n'y a pas de
rapport de force
pas de bons et de méchants pas de combat
d'adrénaline de drames d'héroïsme
pas de grand échiquier alors la paix
serait-elle donc ennuyeuse
une bonne petite guerre civile ou contre
un voisin qui dérange bas ça va secouer
redonner de l'élan de l'emploi voire
divertir non non c'est ça qui est beau
ring et répétitif le même cirque
alors je me suis donné la mission de
trouver comment la paix durable
peut-être une entreprise passionnante
pis et sexy thing la recherche est
d'autant plus intéressante qu'il n'y a
pas une paix mais plein de paix au
pluriel suivant le professeur wolfgang
diederich avec qui j'ai fait un master
d'études de paix à l'université
d'innsbruck
il importe de trouver les dénominateurs
communs et une transcendance commune
dans la pluralité
dp20 plissé car la paix est d'abord une
histoire subjective
elle passe par l'expérience personnelle
seul individu peut dire je suis en paix
ou pas c'est un état d'être une pensée
une sensation la paix est aussi multi
dimensionnelle et systémique
tout se tient
tôt ou tard la paix internationale la
paix sociale la paix familiale la paix
personnel elles sont toutes
interdépendantes
alors voilà le projet rendre la paix
attrayante séduisante sous tous ses
aspects sur le très long terme
c'est simple mais ce n'est pas facile
est-ce que je m'investis dans le malaise
ou dans la paix
de quoi est ce que j'approuve is young
ma famille mon pays avec des conflits ou
avec de la paix au niveau culturel le
niveau culturel et malheureusement
vraiment très la violence est vraiment
très banalisés
quand la terreur n'est pas dans la rue
elle est sur nos écrans elle est dans
les jeux vidéo sous les sapins de noël
dans les feuilletons avant l'heure du
dîner
nous sommes bombardés du contraire de
nos valeurs cela encrasse notre
inconscient endommagent notre sommeil et
toute notre capacité émotionnelle et
d'autres confiance en ce qu'il y a de
beau et de fort en nous et entre nous
rendre la paix plus captivantes que le
drame
ce n'est pas facile rendre la
bienveillance plus réjouissante que la
malveillance
c'est une transformation sociétale et
donc individuel dans les entreprises et
les institutions
je remarque que cette habitude de
critiquer de rejeter de blâmer sur les
autres de s'enfermer dans des alliances
discriminatoire ou dans la victimisation
c'est là que commence le changement avec
une meilleure qualité des relations ou
bien est-ce qu'on s'ennuierait vraiment
si on s'entendait bien
est-ce qu'il manquerait le sel de la
revanche le poivre de l'amertume
les épices du stress le piment des
conflits il faut pas même se battre pour
faire sa place et se démarquer du reste
du troupeau et puis où serait le jus des
émotions si elle était paisible après
tout ce sont ces petites batailles qui
nous donne un sens un sens à nos efforts
et à la justification d'avoir raison
même d'exister
non non non non on tourne en rond un
malaise après l'autre une crise après
l'autre un vrai manège un ça suffit
au niveau global
une hypothèse dit que la paix est la
condition sine qua none pour que
l'humanité prennent enfin son rôle de
serviteur
et de gestionnaires de la planète terre
notre mission est de bien gérer la
diversité des sociétés et des ressources
mais ce n'est qu'un département de
l'entreprise planétaire l'humanité n'est
qu'un sous systèmes dans une grande
écologie elle n'a pas fini ses classes
elle est une apprentie sorcière qui
ignore son mandat parce qu'elle ne met
pas la paix au centre de ces affaires
consciemment et suffisamment une gestion
durable de la planète ne peut se
décliner qu'avec deux systèmes
internationaux ancré dans un discours de
paix nous allons avoir besoin de
beaucoup d'acteurs clés pour faire ce
grand projet et ses acteurs clé ce sont
nous vous toi et toi et moi
individuellement nous sommes interpellés
à transformer nos petites move nos
petits champs de bataille en chant de
paix par l'action cette perspective que
je partage aujourd'hui avec vous je la
dois à mes parents durant la seconde
guerre mondiale mon père devait être
soldat contre l'ennemi mais il pris la
décision irrévocable de ne jamais tirer
sur qui que ce soit la population outre
rhin 10 et il était aussi victime de la
haine et de résidus de conflits mondiaux
antérieur
ce n'était pas le peuple allemand mais
la concurrence des puissances l'armement
à outrance et la folie hitlérienne qui
avait amené le grand conflit
la paix revenue
mes parents profondément pacifiste avait
une bibliothèque des philosophies et des
religions du monde
un jour ma mère tombe sur un article qui
parlait de la fondation de findhorn
situé dans le nord de l'ecosse elle en
parla avec enthousiasme
ai je décidé d'aller voir de quoi il
s'agissait j'avais 18 ans et j'y ai
passé douze années de volontariat
la fondation de findhorn est un centre
de communautaire d'environ 400 personnes
basées sur des valeurs de simplicité
d'égalité et de services à la balle à
payer tangible 1 je me rappelle de deux
principes fondamentaux
l'un big challenge sois toi même le
changement que tu veux voir dans le
monde
c'est une maxime très pédagogique et
thérapeutique à notre principe work is
love in action
le travail c'est l'amour dans l'action
petit à petit nous avons construit un
village écologique avec l'autonomie en
énergie
c'est un modèle d'organisation qui est
transférable
aujourd'hui la fondation à leur rôle de
conseil auprès des nations unies pour
l'enseignement et la réalisation de
systèmes de centre de vie avec la avec
dès le moindre trace carbone et une
économie circulaire et solidaire après
cette période de vie communautaire un
pacifique mais pas sans imperfection je
voulais voir si un tel modèle était
possible à plus grande échelle
c'est à dire dans la société que j'avais
quitté douze ans plus tôt je pensais
qu'il serait bon aussi pour mes enfants
de voir les deux mondes le microcosme de
l'utopie réalisé et ses grands systèmes
qui sont si difficiles
à gérer nous avons continué notre vie en
allemagne
mes activités m'ont mené en centrafrique
et au soudan du sud où j'ai travaillé
avec des faiseurs de paix au coeur des
conflits violents
nous avons cherché à comprendre comment
comment améliorer comment être plus
efficaces dans ce travail de paix
comment réduire les inimitiés tribales
et protéger la paix fragilisé par les
concurrences au pouvoir au bangladesh en
inde en bolivie au mexique au liban au
kenya j'ai eut conduit d évaluation de
projets voués à la paix au développement
et à l'aide
j'ai fait une étude longitudinale au
népal pendant dix ans après la guerre
civile je me suis impliqué avec les
politiciens les entrepreneurs les écoles
les universités les médias les ong pour
faire passer un message de paix
pratiques dans la gestion des systèmes
locaux
ce fut un travail d'éducation et de
communication
notre but était que le que le pays ne
retombe dans le conflit nous avons
appliqué ma formule de paix propre à
cette recherche
c'est une équation qui multiplie la paix
collective par la paix individuel
l'avancement de paix collective à trois
critères qui sont la paix économique
l'équité sociale et le développement
durable x l'avancement de la pêche
individuel avec trois critères qui sont
l'empathie
la confiance de base et la prise en main
ou la prise de contrôle de sa propre vie
l'individuel et au carré selon
l'hypothèse que le choix personnel de
paix précède et détermine la croissance
de paix au collectif les népalaise et
les népalais avaient une telle volonté
d'incarner la paix dans leur quotidien
dans leur société pluraliste avec plus
de 100 familles ethnique et dans la
construction de leur première république
que le pays n'est pas retombé dans
l'insurrection
d'ailleurs tout au long il y avait une
grande masse de paix mais elle avait été
caché par le conflit
bien sûr il fallait travailler le
conflit aussi l'analyser avec toutes les
parties prenantes l'expliqué lui
répondre travailler la paix c'est
travailler le conflit et maintenant je
suis à strasbourg et je regarde l'europe
et je me demande comment continuer à
bâtir la paix durable surtout que
parfois on a l'impression de marcher à
reculons et que la paix semble cacher
ici et là par des discours et des actes
de dissensions comment reprendre le
flambeau parler de cet énorme héritage
de paix les guépards des milliers de
personnes de toutes les cultures et de
tous les temps
comment marcher dans leur empreinte et
continuer ce chemin
emmanuel kant philosophe allemand a
expliqué deux siècles et demi avant la
formation des nations unies qu une
communauté d'états peut garantir la paix
grâce à un certain système législatif
internationale et une ouverture d'esprit
des peuples qui assure l'hospitalité
mutuelle dans leurs mouvements et
l'échangé équitable dans leurs affaires
continuons cela simone veil femme
politique française
défendez passionnément le libre arbitre
elle nous mettaient en garde contre ce
besoin d'appartenance à des idées des
groupements et le positionnement rigide
ans pour et contre qui peut mener
jusqu'à la violence organisée le libre
arbitre la volonté sont des muscles de
l'intelligence à exercer pour construire
les mécanismes de la paix
continuons cela john lennon nous a légué
give peace a chance et imagine imaginer
de quoi aurait l'air un monde en paix
avec lui même si nous ne pouvons pas
l'imaginer nous ne pourrons pas le
planifier continueront cela
en conclusion ne laissons pas aux autres
la gestion des conflits qui nous
concerne tout le monde ne choisit pas
une politique de paix les garants de la
paix ce sont vous et moi
et chacun qui utilise son libre arbitre
pour bien gérer les différences les
dilemmes ne vont pas partir ils sont
incontournables
ils sont aussi une source de progrès la
gestion d'un foyer d'une école d'une
entreprise d'un ministère d'un
territoire
cela implique la gestion de problèmes de
dilemme d'opposition c'est l'objectif de
cette gestion et la manière dont on
traite les problèmes qui seront porteurs
de paix ou pas chacun son petit
territoire
soyons des faiseurs de paix au moins à
l'intérieur de ces territoires
et si nous le voulons même au delà
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]